السلام عليكم ورحمه الله هذا موجز الاخبار
من الجزيره اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن
دخول الفرقاطه الجديده الادمغه القرش كوفا
الخدمه كما اعلنت عن اطلاقه ان تجربي
لصاروخان اسرع من الصوت من الفرقه في مياه
البحر شمال غربي البلان واقل الرئيس
التي تحملها هذه الفرقه تحمل روسيا من
التهديدات الخارجيه
في المقابله وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني
ديميتر كوليبا انه قد تم البدء بالفعل في
نقل انظمه الامريكيه الى اوكرانيا وانه
سيتم نشرها والاستفاده منها في اقرب وقت
للرد على الاعتداءات الروسيه
بدوره قال رئيس الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه ان
بلاده تخطط لسنه هجوم كبير في الربيع
المقبل على مواقع تمركز القوات الروسيه
معتبره ان القتاله في شهر مارس ادارس
سيكون الاشد دراوته
قالت مصادر الدبلوماسيه للجزيره ان مجلس
الامن سيعقدوا اليوم الخميس جلسه لمناقشه
انتهاكات الى احتلال الاسرائيلي في القدس
على خلفيه اقتحام وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي المسجد الاقصى المبارك وقد
اجتمع مجلس السفراء العرب لدى الامم
المتحده وممثلوا منظمه التعاون الاسلامي
مع رئيس مجلس الامن الدولي في نيويورك
تركزت النقاشته على الاستياء العرب
والاسلامي اذا اقتحام الاقصى واكد مصدر
فلسطيني
وقال مندوب فلسطين لدى الامم المتحده رياض
منصور ان ما تريده فلسطين من جلسه مجلس
الامن الدولي هو الوقوف في وجه حكومه
نتنياهو المتطرفه وعدم السماح لها بفرض
ارادتها على المجتمع الدولي
عن معارضتها لاي اجراءات احاديه تقود
الوضع الراهن في الاماكن المقدسه بالقدس
كما وصفت الحكومه الالمانيه اقتحام المسجد
الاقصى بالاستفزازي وداع المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الالمانيه رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه للالتزام بالوضع القائم في
الاماكن المقدسه
الرجاء مجلس النواب الامريكي اعمله حتى
الثامنه مساء بتوقيت واشنطن بعد ان اخفق
على مدار سته جوالات من التصويت خلال
اليومين في انتخاب رئيس المجلس بسبب
معارضه مجموعه من الجمهوريين لترشح الزعيم
الجمهوريين بمجلس النواب كيف رئاسه المجلس
واقل الرئيس
صاحبت عمليه التصويت محرجه ولا تعكس صوره
جيده عن الولايات المتحده
اشكركم على متابعه الموجزه لما كنتم قابلت
اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]